les leaders jane est ce que smaïn est
venu voir votre spectacle oui vous
l'avez il est venu nous féliciter
oui non peut jamais si je te jure il est
fabuleux on fait des sorties vous avez
pas accepter qu'ils viennent de rentrer
dans votre loge quoi ce mail non mais
oui je te jure alors je vais dire que
j'étais dire ce qui s'est passé un
quiproquo sincèrement arrive oui
vraiment un quiproquo ce qui bouge dans
le dictionnaire
et bien voilà qui promet non non
vraiment ma vie alors alors élevés et
les lieux voir le spectacle est en fait
je l'avais en face de moi et j'ai dit
oui
il rigole il rigolait pas parce que y en
fait il analysé le spectacle et riri
jamais je ne savais pas où j'allais pas
que je mette la cage y aller voir ce
spectacle il ne riez pas oui je sais
j'ai trouvé le nom de vos premier one
man show c'est vrai oui c'est vrai oui
non mais oui mais voilà qu'au sprint
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour son
travail pour lui
ok il ya aucun problème est toujours le
même but en plus j ai aucune animosité
simplement quand il est venu voir mon
spectacle parce que moi je regarde tout
le monde quand quand je joue je regarde
les gens dans les yeux et lui dit en
face de moi et riez pas et comme ça mais
que j'aime bien je me dis mais pourquoi
il rit pas à sauvage et le spectacle
comme ça ok non mais moi je pense qu'on
peut applaudir et quand il est monté
dans la loge
il n'a pas fait dans la bonne loges
voilà voilà champion poser une question
à qui vous voulez et le titre made in
quand on est les femelles